[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
T of this program is to provide
nutritional education only this program
is not meant to take the place of your
primary care physician the FDA requires
us to let you know that our products are
not meant to treat prevent diagnose or
cure any diseases as an empowered
individual you have options available we
are honored to have one of the founding
fathers of epigenetics here to guide us
with the best options to obtain or
maintain Optimal Health Dr Joel Wallach
welcome to daily with Doc and Becca
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
nutritional education only this program
is not meant to take the place of your
primary care physician the FDA requires
us to let you know that our products are
not meant to treat prevent diagnose or
cure any diseases as an empowered
individual
record
how I've got the record going
on Zoom on
say something else
I got it okay consume record soon
yes Zoom is recording
we didn't get an announcement that Zim
is recording and there's no Red Dot
really
recording in progress
how's that perfect Sherry
okay
there we go
all right I saw that we're streaming I
shall we're ready to go let's go
everybody is coming into the the room so
you've been in the waiting room thank
you so much for Patiently Waiting I hope
you enjoyed the music my name is Becca
dukes and welcome to daily with Doc
this program is being brought to you as
a resource a resource that enables you
to help yourself I'm all about doing it
yourself I'm all about being an
empowered individual and not relying on
somebody else to tell me what I can and
can't put in my mouth or around my
environment and in this program there
are going to be some things that don't
do this don't do that yes do this but
it's only because the information to
support
these things has been researched and
researched and researched and pathology
reports that prove that what is going to
be said today in today's program are
accurate and true
now if you are watching us on the live
stream you are more than welcome to join
us here in the zoom room with us in the
meeting
and ask your questions of the good
doctor that we have with us feel free to
go to daily with Doc zoom.com and for
those of you who are here with us make
sure that you are following us on
YouTube that's with critical Health news
that's the channel also on Rumble
critical Health news and if you're a
Facebook user
follow us on Facebook critical Health we
want to make sure that the information
is available feel free to share it share
it to your own channels share it with
friends and especially if you have
somebody that has one of this or any of
the symptoms that are mentioned in our
show
you heard the information for a purpose
share it with them so they can hear the
information also and they can then make
an educated decision to choose Health
choose wellness and do it through
nutritional options because folks we are
not chemical deficient we are mineral
deficient we are nutrient deficient when
we are just plagued with so many
different negative health symptoms
and it doesn't have to be that way so I
am
privileged and honored to be the hostess
of this program
where we present Dr Joel Wallach Dr
Wallach has an amazing and incredible
I
I want to say pedigree but that's not
the word I mean his whole resume and
everything that he has done in his short
83 Years starting at the age of nine is
absolutely incredible in building
information that people can actually
Implement into their own lives without
having a prescription
and he has done this through being a
student
being a pathologist being a veterinarian
being a naturopathic physician all
around the world he is helping people
now Dr Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
I know I'm well we're hoping that we
have a special guest on with us as well
so we're keeping our eye out for for him
but go ahead Dr Wallace Rebecca he is in
the house
oh fantastic folks
um you know I'm excited about having Dr
Wallach on every day but when we can put
these two men together
two veterans one from Air Force and army
the other a retired Navy SEAL it is just
an honor and privilege because these two
have worked together to do some
incredible things and if you have
watched Dr Wallach other places he's
mentioned this gentleman's name
Marvin Rob Marvin Dr Wallach
join me here please
because I know you've got some amazing
things to share I'm gonna add you both
to the screen if people would stop
jumping around
and
welcome gentlemen so yes Dr Wallach is
holding up the book
prepare which they both including Dr
wallach's wife Dr Milan who is retired
from the Chinese Air Force correct yes
10 years Chinese Air Force
and
Marvin
share with us and start us off
Marvin have done because
it's incredible in the story
of the cause and cure of so many
different diseases where you can say it
I can't
but it's an incredible story that I
think the world needs to hear so welcome
Marvin
Thank You Marvin for being on thumbs up
okay I guess my audio's on is that
correct it's gone you're on now let's
Let me give a little introduction here
and we'll turn over you for a while
um but a little introduction
um
remember that uh I'm the guy that I was
working at the your case your keys
Primary Center were the Space Monkeys
and um I ran into the first case of a
non-human case of cystic fibrosis and I
recognized it being a pathologist and
having done twenty thousand autopsies by
then and so
um I took slides from these baby monkeys
and sent them to experts uh in Cisco
Bros Associated to five medical schools
and said I think this is cynical roses
what do you think but I didn't tell them
the slides were from monkeys I just said
you know these are pathology slides and
they assumed it was from people
and they say oh yeah these are classic
examples of cereal brosis and then I
wrote back on this because he sent that
to me in their letterhead this was we're
talking 1976 okay under letterhead so I
wrote him back and called them and said
hey I think we may have an animal model
here because these are slides from
monkey from a monkey and then I got
permission because on their letterhead
they said it was cigarosis they allowed
me to do biopsies on the other 24 baby
monkeys are being groomed to go to space
and they all had physical brosis because
the people who are in charge of the diet
of this Colony uh had taken the monkey
pellets away from them with all the
vitamins and minerals in it just gave
them fruit and vegetables and all these
baby monkeys had the nutritional
deficiencies which resulted in the uh
cisiberosis
and when I told him it wasn't a genetic
thing that we could give them all the
baby monkeys they wanted with citibrosis
to study they fired me just abruptly
fired me and my wife had died I had four
little kids and since it was kind of a
crazy time
and
um to make a long story short I started
going to all these events and trade
shows or anything looking for something
and I ran into these naturopathic
schools I'd never heard of naturopathic
doctors before and so I went to to make
loans very short I
um got a job teaching nutrition at the
naturopathic College in Portland Oregon
was ends NC M Nature Valley College okay
um oh national college national college
of nature chronic medicine in Portland
Oregon
teaching nutrition I said well I'm here
I might as well take courses and get the
degree which I did graduated in 1982 as
a naturopathic doctor
and then I realized the Nature Valley
doctors couldn't help many people you
know you'd see two or three people a day
or maybe 10 people a day if you're
really good at it but there was
Insurance didn't pay for their services
and everything so people weren't
flocking to Nature Valley doctors
so I began to do my own lectures up and
down the west coast and that's when I
decided to build an army I I have many
many slides say look we got to build an
army here and train people and you know
now we have the
the
um let's see here the what do you call
it
the health coaches we have the health
coaches now okay which are certified
they get a certificate and we have I
don't know maybe 1200 certified health
coaches now going around teaching other
people how to do this sort of thing but
when I was running into at that time I'm
running into uh remember all these birth
defects that's why my thesis is in the
Smithsonian it's it's natural treasure
because there are no genuinely
transmitted birth defects there's no
autoimmune diseases they're all
nutritional fishes they just and Marvin
Rob had just kind of retired from being
a Navy SEAL a decorated Navy SEAL what
25 years in the Navy
that was 20 years doc 20 years okay and
everybody stayed longer because they
said hey you got done enough for us it's
time for you to become a civilian
oh you did and he's a co-author in this
book okay with Dr Milan myself in all
his story is on the back not all his
story but a summary of his stories in
the back of the book here we're very
proud of of um Marmon okay and so
basically he is from sort of the
Northwest we're talking about Utah and
Idaho and Washington and Oregon and so
forth and they had a very high rate
of mustard dystrophy all right not
because of a genetic thing but because
of the eating habits and the location
because of what was in the soil was not
in the soil
and so Marvin jumped on this and helped
me I couldn't be there every day I had
you know my practice up and down the
west coast and I was trying to see as
many people as I could and so I couldn't
just stay in that area forever and so
Marvin kind of took over and really
worked for these families they had kids
was muster this fee and I have to say
that we got rid of my fishing was it's a
nutritional disease and it's not it's
neutral deficient it's either during
pregnancy or immediately after pregnancy
okay and so it's not one of those things
where it's a genetic disease and tell us
some of your early experiences with
these
with these kids you're already in the
youngevity program and it may have been
American Longevity at that time when you
first came it was American Longevity
first came in or was it when I first
came in in 2002 it was American
Longevity but when I went full time in
2008 my wife and I went full time as
young Germany coaches uh basically
joined your Crusade doc January 2008
we've been doing it full-time ever since
so uh one of my first case of muscular
dystrophy was actually uh that I really
started making the connection was uh in
2008 and then what ended up happening is
that
um in working in Indiana I got into a
community
that is known to have large percentage
of their children born with birth
defects and also muscular dystrophy now
I never made the connection to Muscular
Dystrophy and kishan's disease until one
day I was talking to Doc and I said this
is January 2009 I said doctor says you
know I said there's this one Community
that's just a large number of children
born with most tradition if you're
kidding me do anything for them and doc
says what says where's this at that says
what is Adams County Indiana and so I
said uh that's the same as keeshawn's
disease and of course I remember him
talking about keyshawn's disease this is
really I did not make that connection of
course I was just learning a lot of
things and that's one thing Doc taught
me is in the early days more of an if
you can
I ate so dark so how am I supposed to go
out and teach people what you're doing
is it Marvin you don't have to be a PhD
in compared to pathology all you have to
do is learn how to recognize the
symptoms of a failed system for example
you've got neurological disorders and
got digestive disorders but going back
to musculoskeletal so muscular dystrophy
falls into a musculoskeletal problem and
so he said just learn how to connect the
dots and that's really how simple it is
you'll be able to walk circles around
doctors and so okay well that sounds
simple enough and so now I had no idea
what that meant at the time but as time
go went on I understood so that
connection I made the connection to the
dots make a long story short March of
2009 we went out and uh I take that back
it was not until I have my dates wrong
it was uh
2008 2009-2010 is when I start working
with the Amish communities in the
midwest but then I came across this
community in around 2009 2010 but it was
not until the spring of 2011 is when we
actually got able to get in there and do
do some work with the community and by
this time
we had the community was the sad part
about it was that there's a lot of
medical doctors and people the medical
profession that come in and done
research and promised these families
help
but no help ever came they got the data
they wanted and they turned around about
their thesis or whatever it was and and
of course it was so-called a genetic
disorder and that was basically a major
letdown time and time and time again so
when we when we came into that Community
they just thought we're just another
data grabbing you know scientist that
wants to get a name for himself and but
we actually went around and we had a
pretty large attendance in our first
meeting there uh Amos Wiki was there I
like to tell this story about him as
Wiki now Emma's Wiki I had got him
started on he was in Southern Indiana
but he grew up in Adams County he was
diagnosed as little girl muscular
dystrophy at an early age and by the
time I got a whole I got introduced to
him in 2009 he was in a wheelchair
at age 38 years old and so if we had him
on the products for over 18 months and
he was able to get out up out of his
wheelchair and walk now
bear in mind the older you are with
muscular dystrophy you have a lot of
scar tissue develop and build up and
things like that so scar tissue is very
difficult to deal with when you're
dealing with muscle tissue but if you
get a hold of these young kids that are
showing the first symptoms of muscular
density but get them on docs protocols
we see results very quickly and so let
me kind of run a little bit through here
so let me go back to Amos Wicca so Amos
Wiki was there at our first Dr Wallach
seminar in the Adams County Indiana and
we had this this this outdoor building
is to call their buggy it was
packed full about 150 200 people doc
would you say that yes yeah so Amos Wiki
had came up early he had hired himself
for chauffeur to bring him up because
zombies don't have they have horse and
buggers so he came from Switzerland
County Indiana which one in Southern
Indiana came up to personally meet Dr
Wallach and he wanted to meet this guy
look this guy is able to get me up out
of the wheelchair and walk so doc had a
little bit of personal time with Amos
Wiki before where we started the seminar
I was out there getting everything ready
and so
unbeknownst to me I did not know a doc
had something up his sleeve when uh Amos
Wiki came out there he was sitting his
wheelchair up front and Dr Wallach comes
in and starts this lecture of course
about half an hour into the lecture one
of these skeptical Amish men stoods up
and said okay Dr Wallach
if you're so sure of what you're saying
how what is it going to be when
Amos is going to get up and walk
well now Doc had just prepared for this
time it was so funny because all of a
sudden Dr Wallach stops his lecture he
turns over towards Amos and you know if
he could just visualize Moses holding
his staff over the Red Sea and and Dr
Wallach points to Amos Amos get up and
walk
all of a sudden Amy slips his head up he
gets up out of his wheelchair he needs a
couple of 360s and sets down in his
wheelchair well all of a sudden
everybody in that room starts speaking
Dutch
now I can speak Dutch because I grew up
Amish I understand what they're saying
and Doc looked at me and says oh my did
I offend these people what am I doing
you know so are they going to crucify me
or what and uh and so uh then doc
immediately had to admit okay I I have
to admit I already knew that Amos could
walk we just kind of role play this
because Amos was not able to walk 18
months ago but now he's able to because
he's on this product
and this is the broad group I talk about
so the hush hush it kind of settled down
a little bit and so we got their
attention
but with that said we collected a lot of
data and Dr remember Levi's Levi you
know they always had Levi's Levi's Levi
which is the grandfather's son was Levi
and his grandson's name Levi he was 10
years old now Levi
Levi's Levi uh which is the grandson of
Grandfather Levi got on the products at
10 years old and at that time Levi's
Levi's Levi was not able to do play
basketball he could no longer shoot you
know when you shoot the Hoops in the
basketball you kind of squat down and
and shoot it but he could no longer
Squat and kind of do that jump when he
uh you know serve the basketball hoop so
I'm not a basketball player so bear with
me if I could butcher your basketball
terms for your basketball fans but so he
would just sit on the sidelines within
less than three months Levi's Levi's
Levi was able to play basketball
and so that was when we really started
noticing a significant Improvement in
the the kids that are on the protocol of
course we still had a lot of skepticism
and that's okay people entitled to the
skepticism in their opinion but it was
irrefutable irrefutable had a little
Levi he was 10 years old and within less
than six months he was able to play
basketball now what we learned from that
little extent that little testimony is
that we learned Dr Wallach called a
squat test
and
what I mean by the squat test we
interviewed all these families they have
large families anywhere from I mean it
was not uncommon for 12 to 14 children
per family and half the kids with
muscular discipline the other half was
not so there's a couple things we came
up with that we observed number one is
that we do soil we went to the local
Purdue University and we got soil
samples of Adams County Indiana and lo
and behold we discovered
that the soil content of selenium
deficiency was almost identical of what
keyshawn's county China was there was no
selenium soil matter of fact by law the
feed companies had to put extra selenium
in the animal feed in order to prevent
white muscle disease stiff land disease
and mulberry heart disease matter of
fact Mulberry heart disease was first
discovered in Adams County Indiana which
is actually a muscular distance of the
heart muscle so all of a sudden these
dots start to connect and Dr Wallach
I've never seen such an excited
scientist in my world he was in his
element He was collecting notes and
things like that now we were not allowed
to take pictures of the Amish because
the the refrain for us taking pictures
but we did one family allowed us to take
pictures of the back profile of them so
we have those documented and so as we
take collection we took hair samples and
things like that of all these families
that what was interesting is this is
that we discovered some very interesting
things number one we discovered how to
detect muscular discipline these
children long before the symptoms were
available so the first symptoms of
muscular dystrophy were the kids by
seven or eight years old they were
starting to fall and stumble when they
ran in school when they're running you
know they play base a softball or a
running you know playing Kick the Can or
something like that when they run they
start stumbling and falling because
they're losing strength in their quads
their quad muscles so I assume that's
what you call your thigh muscles it quad
muscles that they called quad muscle
thigh muscles yeah okay they're starting
losing strength in that and you start
seeing the calves getting bigger and
bigger and eventually they could not go
up and down stairs they had to pull
themselves up the stairs and eventually
could no longer go up and down stairs
then they knew but okay well within
three four years you're gonna be in a
wheelchair by the time we're 12 13 years
old they're used in the wheelchair
but what we discovered is long before
those symptoms came on board we
discovered that if they have these
little kids I mean as the youngest two
years old at two years old we would have
them uh Place their hands on their hips
and feet shoulder width apart we had
them squat down
straight down and come all the way back
out
those who had been
those who have musculinity or were
headed towards muscular dystrophy they
could not do the squat test remember
that doc it was a simple little test and
it was amazing these kids could still
run they could still run up and down
stairs but they could not squat down and
come back up
okay because they did not have the
strength in their quads to do so and
within three or four years they will
then start to stumble and so it'd be
caught early on we got them on the
protocol and they could they had no
problems with with a squat test matter
of fact we've got evidence of kids that
within six months time they were able to
do the squat test for before they could
not do it so early on prevention is a
key right there and that we discovered
now as they mature into their disease
stages different uh stages of uh of that
scar tissue buildup it was more
difficult to uh
we were able to stop it from getting
worse put it that way we saw some
improvement but not back to complete
reversal of it so the key was get them
on the products do the squat tests and
we went through all those families we
didn't have to do blood tests or nothing
like that we just did a squat test if
they failed the squat test guess what we
bought them on a product and just like
those families who did it those children
were healthy
and so I have a handwritten testimony of
Levi's Levi by the time he was 15 he was
an adult now he was working on a
construction crew a roofing crew
and so he told me so Marvin I can go up
and down that ladder with no problem the
only thing I can see is that my Lasik my
legs are not quite as strong as as my
peers are instead of carrying what two
bundles of shingles I can only carry one
bundle of shingles well that's pretty
good accomplishment as far as I'm
concerned he was not in a wheelchair
and so uh we have a handwritten note
from him of his testimony and it's
actually uh available to the public and
it's on a website we have all the most
suggested information out there it's a
great little test Amish handwritten note
you know a 15 year old and he just said
well just he just told well this is what
I do well can you put that in writing
okay well sure I'll put it in writing
not a problem so we did that so doc uh
so credit to that
um I'd like to tell this side of the
story because doctors not like to brag
about himself but I'm going to brag
about DACA for a second here
and he kept saying oh this is a this is
a bombshell this is a bombshell of
course we've got more information from
Purdue University and and we just you
know the soil analysis and the gardens
the Amish people in the gardens they
were raising food out of the gardens and
we noticed that it was the Amish in that
Adams County we're having the problem
not the non-obvish not Amish but buying
their food from the grocery stores they
didn't have any issues there so the
conclusion came is that well that's
because there's not enough selenium in
the garden vegetables and fruits and
vegetables that raised to feed their
families because they had large families
and they were basically
feeding their families with a very low
selenium diet matter of fact not enough
selenium in the soil to sustain healthy
reproductive capability according to
Purdue University for AG industry so you
think about it the agriculture industry
had this already nailed down but no
medical doctor that came in there
previous to our research ever made that
connection I never made that suggestion
to the families of Adams County Indiana
something else we discovered doc that
was just phenomenal doc got caught on to
this very quickly is that
every single mother
every child that was every mother had
given birth to a child with muscular
dystrophy she was also gluten intolerant
we went back to the Next Generation the
mother the grandmother was gluten
tolerant and we were able to go back
four generations the great grandmother
every single female that had a genealogy
with children must do this for every
single female mother mom that given
birth to uh these children were gluten
intolerant so what does that tell us
well first of all the mother is not
digesting the nutrients like he should
because it damaged the gluten and second
of all if you're eating food that is not
as low in selenium that just expands a
problem so something else we discovered
it was really profound now we discovered
this later on a few years later but we
went back and look at the regulars and
lo and behold there it was right in
front of us that was that
80 percent of these children born to
these Amish mothers Mennonite mothers
this is a ride Specter 80 percent of
these children born but so-called
genetic disorder premature babies birth
defect or some kind of a hygienic
disorder or birth defect right they were
can see late summer winter and fall late
summer fall and winter months
80 percent of these children
now that was a simple observation it
didn't take a rocket scientist figure
that out but once again as doc taught me
connect the dot smart I mean connect to
the dots okay so what we found out is
that
if what was that mother doing in the
spring and early summer months that
reduced the risk of having a child with
a birth defect or so-called degenic
disorder
what was she doing well guess what she
was doing she was out in the garden she
was working the garden getting plenty of
sunshine vitamin D3 and was getting
enough nutrients from those fresh fruits
and vegetables to continue to develop a
healthy healthy embryo
that has I have I just got off the phone
with a lady uh two days ago and she had
two children the first one was born four
weeks early the second one was born four
weeks early but it had a birth defect
and and sure enough that child was
conceived in the month of November
this is so it's just it's mind-blowing
it should be a Nobel Peace Prize stuff
it's mind-blowing that a little Amish
boy from Missouri can figure this out I
don't know how that's possible doc
without divine intervention but I
believe in divine intervention but Dr
Wallach you you you brought this you
know you had pioneered the study so
I remember very vividly when I drop you
off the airport June of 2011 at Fort
Wayne Indiana and we were a little bit
early I ran in real quick make sure that
we can check your bags in and they said
oh sure come on in you know it's about
five hours before your flight and so I
came out in my rental car here was Dr
Warlock and I'm gonna say I know doc
won't say it but I'm gonna share this
and Doc had his sitting in the passenger
he had his head like this he was
going like this oh my God oh my God the
world oh my God I wish my mom and dad I
wish my mom and dad were alive to see
what's about to happen
now I did not know this but Dr wallach's
mother had just passed away six months
before that
see Dr Wallach and I'm getting emotional
when I share this because Dr wallach's
mother believed in Dr Wallach so much
that with that he she saw a couple of
her hip of their Farms to fund Dr alik's
trip to China with Dr Milan to do the
resource on the kishan's disease in
keyshons County China
now unbeknownst to me unbeknownst to me
I had no idea what was about to happen
but this research we got from Adams
County Indiana was submitted to Dr
Gerhard strauser the Trish element of
research as a result Dr Wallach was
awarded the cloud Schwartz medal of
accommodation because he was able to
compare Adams County Indiana
to keyshawns County China also to his
discovery of cystic fibrosis monkey
those three
connected dots the science was
irrefutable
those three is what gave him
the clown Source medal of accommodation
now to me that's a higher honor than the
Nobel Prize and the reason why is
because only scientists who discover
Ed the benefits of selenium
will ever receive that award and Dr
Wallach was the first competitive
pathologist and first veterinarian to
ever received that award so that's not
given out every every year it's only
given out when a major discoveries
created from the from the benefits of
selenium in my correct doc
you're correct there it is it's quite
the honor thank you for bringing the
head up
yeah thank you and of course
um the cloud short it was presented to
me by um let's see here by Dr Gerhart
schroser who was one of the Premier
biochemists in the world
okay and he was the one who presented
that award to me okay
um they're uh in I think it was it was
in Arizona or Indiana
one of the two I don't even remember
okay but he presented that award to me
and then just
um a few years later for the same same
work
I received a Lifetime Achievement Award
from the United Nations
okay and so that was a another who huh
okay there's a picture of me getting
that award in the office for the United
Nations in New York City okay
and then again this is uh you me and uh
Dr Milan okay putting this book together
to let everybody know what they needed
to do was keep things straight
um actually help everybody avoid all
these terrible diseases were said to be
genetic which are not and so I cannot
thank you enough for that history and
um uh it's one of those things where the
story uh is in the book
um epigenetics it's in the book Dead
Doctors Don't Lie and it's one of those
things where
there's very very few people in their
lifetime get a chance to save
kids and so we're very very proud of
them we cannot thank you enough for all
that you did to make sure that this got
the word was out there because I
couldn't be there all the time so you
were there
greater time than I was and you're
taking care of people with that
information providing the information
and coaching them so we cannot thank you
enough and so in effect you shared in
that
um Omar the cloud Schwartz award so I'll
have to buy you dinner
well Dr Wallach I want to uh like I said
I spent a lot of time with you on the
phone and I you know one of the things
most people don't know this but I always
tell people that I owe Dr Wallach my
health and I owe him my family and
that's a whole other subject under the
time but I want to kind of expand on
this uh this whole pic big picture of
Amish janika's Waters there's 168
so-called Amish genic disorders last
time not the one I checked but what
what's what's just a absolute crime is
that the medical profession has
victimized the Amish communities the
bigger the Amish communities the greater
victimization what they do is they have
these geneticists come in and they do
Gene profile of the of the Amish and
then they victimize them by saying oh
you've got this bad Gene and it's
nothing you can do but you need to
donate money to us so we can do research
and to look for it here they have been
doing benefit auctions in Holmes County
and Pennsylvania Ohio and Indiana the
three largest states of large Amish
communities thousands and thousands and
thousands of families
and they will raise per benefit options
they will raise millions and millions of
dollars that goes to these geneticists
they will go back to the lab and never
come back with a cure for years they've
been doing this
but Dr Wallach and I were in the in the
office of a guy now A guy by the name
but Ed Klein from Holmes County Ohio he
was one of the biggest scammers in the
community in my opinion and I'm going to
be blunt with that now
on the special needs kids aboard there
was 12 members of the Amish communities
12 members of Amish communities
all of those 12 members except Ed Klein
had special needs kids so they were used
to help support this non-profit
organization
but Dr Wallach and I set it in plan's
Office doc you remember that
Ed Klein's office and I asked Ed Klein
and I was explaining this to Ed Klein
and he was just the walls were coming up
walls are coming up walls are coming up
and he tried to quote all this
brainwashed genetic disorder crap right
which he Ed Klein had no idea who Dr
walek was
so Ed Klein did not know I could speak
Dutch
ha
he did not know what my background was
but I made a very clear Point Ed let me
ask you a question
of all you are on the board of 12 people
I did my research before I came in here
in his office I had a conversation with
you because we're inviting you to come
to the lecture tonight okay
with all these geneticists and the
nurses that they hire to run around and
make sure all the Amish families are in
line with the genetic code disorders I
said it says
you're the only member on that board
that does not have a special needs kids
why do you think that is
he looked at me so I never thought of it
that way he said well
I picked up on that everybody else all
those living families and I know them
all they have a special needs kids
why do you think they pick you
he couldn't answer the questions well I
can tell you why Ed
you were a very successful businessman
you as an Amish man own a big lumber
yard here
you are so you are seen by the Amish
community is a very reputable man and
they had listened to what you had to say
they are using you as a as a as a member
of the community to fleece the flock
and of course Dr Wallach allowed me a
little breath have a little I just got I
kind of interrupted Doc and Ed's
conversation but then I made that
comment and Ed thought a little bit then
he came back with his
genetic profile rendering so I stopped
him I started speaking in Dutch to him
and remember His look on his face doc
remember they're looking at space when I
started speaking Dutch to him
I could speak Dutch too because that's
the Afrikaans language
all of a sudden this guy realized that
after about five minutes the Dutch
conversation I kind of set his mind
straight says look you know so I
understand where you're coming from but
don't you realize that you may have been
deceived and lied to you're you're an
instant of used a free stuff lock
so
make a long story short we had 30
minutes of Ed Klein we invited him to
come to our lecture that night at Keim
Lumber of all places kind Lumber
he didn't show up but guess who showed
up
Dr Walt do you remember that time in
kind Lumber where that doctor it was
five nurses there trying to disrupt our
meeting
I remember the disruption yes yeah yeah
so basically I did not know what was
going on I didn't pick up on it I I had
brought doc back from his hotel after
he's doing a radio show we went upstairs
to the conference room about 250 people
uh conference room and right next to the
our conference it was another conference
room and guess a doctor from the local
hospital had read at that conference
room
with five nurses they had a big sign out
front free health lecture
because we had advertised in a paper
free Health Collection
and they had all these gluten-free I
mean they had all these uh cookies a
whole bunch of gluten stuff cookies out
front you know and said oh and as is
Amish famous are coming here these
nurses would come out there and they're
all nicely dressed up night I mean they
were really nice very attractive ladies
we need this to say they would come up
to the Amish famous are you here for the
fifth elements oh yeah well sign here's
a clipboard sign here and come over here
they were fleecing the people into the
wrong conference room
and as I walked up the stairs with Dr
Wall doctor will aggressed my arms and
Martin do you have any any business
cards like oh yes I have them here so
give me all this I'll take care of this
mess
a handful of business cards he said
Marvin you start that meeting I'll be
there in a minute I'll take care of
these guys now I did not know who they
were
but what ended up happening is this is
that pretty soon I was up there got the
meeting started and it filled up and uh
about half hour later Dr Wallace comes
in and says okay well that mess is taken
care of but see what happened is this is
that every time an Amish couple comes up
and introduce these nurses
Dr Walter just gets in front of them and
says are you here for the Dr Wallach
seminars well yeah this is the door you
go into don't listen to these ladies and
so he was just in their face and that's
what she had to do these this doctor and
these nurses had the gall to come out
and try to disrupt our meeting
and this is why
the Amish do not have medical insurance
they are self-insured so if somebody has
a catastrophic hospital bill the
community puts together and they pay it
my insurance company when they send a
bill to my insurance company my
insurance company has a contract with my
HMO to pay a certain amount was about 50
percent of retail
do you think the Amish get that same
break no they charge them retail price
for every hospital visit every office
visit everything
they only have one person that all the
money comes to
and that money is held in a special fund
and those doctors make sure that man
will not spend that money for anything
else but hospital bills and medical
doctors and things like that he's not
even allowed to use that money for
prevention
that's how much control they have all
those Amish people
Dr Wallach and I went in 2010 we went to
the board the committee that manages the
uh the uh
uh all these different diseases and we
got there a line item list of all the
medical bills over 10 million dollars in
that one Amish community 10 million
dollars
of medical bills
about and and we went through that those
medical bills and we identified
all of these different diseases that are
preventable
all but one all but one
and we sat down with the finance
Community explain to them look I know
you're self unsure we're not trying to
pose upon what you're doing but we can
show you how to save millions of dollars
if you start a good prevention program
we can teach you how to prevent these
over over a period of 10 years you could
reduce your out-of-pocket expenses by
easy 30 if not more if not 50 percent
they looked at us they thought we were
crazy
they didn't get it
and how much has the cost of medical
expenses going up since 2010
foreign substantially
they don't get a break they don't get a
break
an average baby premature baby costs an
Amish family over three hundred thousand
dollars in hospital bills
now here comes the good news here comes
the good news
every Amish family that I have worked
with with special needs kids
those mothers who chose to do Dr Wallace
protocol
implemented 100 gluten-free diet
got the products got rid of the gluten
of the household 100 gluten-free in the
house so that's everybody
those mothers who did that not a single
mother since they got on the program I
had hundreds of them not a single mother
has given birth to a child prematurely
with a birth defect so-called genetic
disorder or miscarry
not a single mother if they did the
program correct I have a handful of
mothers who decided to pick and choose
Dr Wallace protocol because they thought
they know who the doc does
well they ended up having birth some
birth defects so I sat down with them
explain them look you cannot pick and
choose you've got to go 100 gluten free
because you're not absorbing your
nutrients you've got to make sure you
supplement your body with all the raw
materials in order to develop a healthy
embryo once you did that not a problem
not a problem
and so that is I mean it's so
irrefutable I mean ideal but large
families and my deal with families that
have children as large as 14 16 so I've
seen as many as 17 children in the
family
but it's it's not uncommon to have six
to eight kids in the family ten I would
send average Amish families about eight
six to eight children uh but there's
more and more young mothers uh suffering
from major major
uh birth defects Genghis orders and
premature babies and whatever
so I just can't think doc enough for all
the stuff he's done for the Amish thank
you well thank you for the history
Marmon we can't thank you enough uh
we're gonna make a tool out of this
because this information must get out
there we're going to make a tool out of
this and this could be a chapter in one
of the next books
um I cannot thank you enough for your
service which obviously is ongoing
thank you sir we appreciate you and
respect you and um uh thank you for a
lot of the detail which I've was not
aware of in many cases but uh thank you
so much for bringing all that up and
it's one of those things where
um we have lots to do we have lots of
kids to say we have lots of families to
say we have lots of humans to save all
over the world and we're expanding we're
just so honored to have you as part of
the army thank you very much
this is just tip of the iceberg
well I agree that's why now we're
building an army and we have you know
people like Rebecca here uh who uh a
great organizer and with your
information and her organization
capacity and the fact that we're dealing
with communities in over 80 countries
right now we do Zooms in the UK we do
Zooms in the Philippines we do Zooms in
Australia New Zealand we do Zooms in
Taiwan we we do Zooms in Japan we do
zooms and just about every state United
States and then then
um Canada okay it's one of those things
where
we're everywhere now and the
communication Electronics is going to
make it easier and easier and easier for
us and so
um you know we're going to come up with
a another
um issue of the survival Bible we can't
thank you enough it'll be a good one for
with all this detail but we'll we'll
make this tool available to you so that
you can make sure that everybody you
know that needs it is going to get that
tool okay
well I am blown away because I knew a
lot at least I thought I knew a lot
Marvin about your Journeys with Dr
Wallach and the research and stuff that
went on but oh my goodness
I I just knew like the tiny tiniest tip
of the iceberg and folks those of you
who are watching us here live in the
zoom or watching the live streams
whether you're on rumble or YouTube or
Facebook
this is information that needs to be
heard you're not going to hear it
anywhere else where else are you going
to find
free information that is pointing people
to
something that's actually going to work
instead of just asking for a lot of
money to find a cure it's already been
found folks and that is our jobs and our
passion Marvin has been absolutely
incredible
I have heard so many good things about
him from more than just Dr Wallach
that these are the type of people that
we have with us here within youngevity
people who truly do care about Humanity
and getting the information out to them
and helping them get the nutritional
supplementation that the body can
actually use and absorb
that is that Dr Wallach you're right
this is going to be a great tool
and I look forward to more conversations
with Marvin here being on with us
yeah with the electronics we have now we
can do zooms all over the world and
include Marvin he wants to yeah
yes absolutely around the world and the
nice thing about having it digital and
having it recorded and out on these
different platforms Dr Wallach
people can share it and share it and
share it and share it
so this one Zoom right now
as I was looking I think we had over 300
people watching wow and that doesn't
that doesn't include the people that are
here on in the zoom with us
and share it
think of what an impact in a hurting
hurting world
this one message could make if it saves
one kid it's worth it but just think
we're going to save tens of thousands of
kids with this information that Marvin
laid out here
absolutely and Marvin was saying how you
know the the soil was deplete of
selenium in their communities
well that's just like a targeted little
group that was we were able to figure
out okay
it proves what Dr Wallach says that
minerals occur in veins like gold silver
and quadruple ice cream
so we need to make sure that we are
intentionally each and every day heating
the raw ingredients that the body needs
in a form that it can actually utilize
and be absorbed into the cells so that
the body can do what it was designed to
do and that is to generate over and over
healthy cells for a long life okay I
want to interrupt here if I made just
one second spring is coming one second
okay spring is coming
okay and there's gonna be a lot of
babies made here this coming spring okay
and so we need to be getting all these
young couples on the 90 essential
nutrients get them off all the bad foods
get them off the gluten the wheat bun
around oats and buckwheat and fago
Pyrenees and all these bad things
so they can get the nutrition so the
babies will be born healthy
um I got the Klaus Schwartz award for
for three things one was the cystic
fibrosis
um Discovery one for the Massachusetts
Discovery and and Marvin how much time
did you spend with Jerry Lewis
well uh this was interesting that's a
whole other subject about Jerry Lewis
and violet and all this resources
submitted to Jerry Lewis and the uh
Jerry Lewis films production now with
that said uh on and off I was on the
phone with a violet more than once uh oh
I had just half a dozen times we faxed
some other results and things like that
but what's interesting is this is that
um we I got a phone call from Jerry
Lewis but I wasn't able to take the call
he just left the message and then I
never heard from him again but that was
after he got fired yeah they fired him
and he brought them he brought them the
College of engine cure of monstrously
they fired Jerry Lewis shut down the
Telethon where he had raised 2.6 billion
dollars over 46 years for them they've
fired Jerry Lewis put a gag order on him
so he couldn't say anything what a
terrible thing the muscles Association
did but we're so glad that you and I
were able to spend time with him so that
he actually got the information and he
knew before he died which was just a
couple years later he knew that we had
found the Cure
and I was just so happy about that part
now I I remember that phone call we did
with it was actually a three-way phone
call but Dr Wallach Violet his secretary
at the journalist films production in
Las Vegas Las Vegas Nevada and spring of
2012 and so she says gentlemen I cannot
answer your questions
and Dr wallach's wisdom he said well
violet
can you say yes or no to my questions
what do you mean
and that doc said well since you live in
Las Vegas it's the sun shining well yes
of course it is right now it's daylight
okay you get the point then Dr Wallach
asked her a bunch of questions of
questions and she said yes no yes no yes
no and guess what we found out
we found out that Jerry Lewis had a gag
order on him from that series of
questions
she wanted to talk so bad
so bad but she knew she could not do it
but we were able to draw the information
out with yes no yes no yes no yes no
that's Dr Wallace interrogation
technique that he hasn't used yet
yes special training special training
to
um his next program we just thank you so
much Dr Wallach you have a fabulous day
and folks normally we have q a where
people can come and raise their hand and
ask questions and I know we have a full
room full of questions but I just think
I couldn't stop it
okay forgive me the information that was
just shared I could not stop so if you
are on and you have questions please go
to daily withdoc.com use that contact us
and send in questions
Marvin
I look forward to many many more
conversations with you as we are sharing
these stories that are
so full of hope so full of light coming
from a heart
I mean folks you can see it in his face
he has a heart for people
like Dr Wallach
and I'm gonna brag on you because you
don't
I've heard some of your stories some of
your seminars I've heard stories about
you
you did 20 years serving your country
and you were not done serving Humanity
so I don't know which you feel is
greater your 20 years as a Navy SEAL
or
that how many years what 30 years almost
30 years now
I've been on the young Championship
products for over 20 years but I've been
doing this full-time since 2008 and I
can honestly tell you it's a lot of fun
to shoot big guns and blow things up but
it's much greater rewards when you help
people especially people have lost hope
they have lost hope
when you can sit down with them and give
them a glimmer of hope
give them a glimmer of hope
it is so rewarding and one maybe we'll
have time to talk about my wife Julie
and I how we went through struggles with
our infertility
and so that's a whole nother separate
story and uh I I says this is just tip
of the iceberg tip of the iceberg and I
do not mind sharing my testimonies and
my experiences because I think that
gives people hope
that's it and that's what I'm here I
mean because I was in a very dark place
and I was searching and I found my hope
I found my answers with Dr Wallach his
message and the youngevity products
so
we're at the end of our program I just
want to thank you and all that are
watching
that have served in the military doesn't
matter what country you were standing up
and supporting your country serving for
others thank you so much for your
service I have a few people that I truly
appreciate who are Navy in addition to
Army and Air Force so Dr Wallach is Air
Force and army my father Army I know
that our co-hosts some of their family
have been in the military and we greatly
and appreciate all the sacrifice that
they have done in the past and For You
Marvin I know that sharing this message
has added some other sacrifices but you
have gotten some great great Joys from
it as well well thank you
so thank you so much and on behalf of
the daily with Doc crew we have Phyllis
Anderson Marilyn pizera Sherry Browning
and Ruth Ellen Sanchez I couldn't do
this without them and it's because of
people like Marvin Rob who have
gotten out there and done some really
hard work in getting information to
people and collecting what is possible
so that we could share it with you so
thank you everybody for joining us here
on daily with Doc we do air Monday
through Friday from noon to 1 Pacific
time our replays can be found on daily
with Doc daily with doc.com
and also on Rumble YouTube and Facebook
we look forward to seeing you next time
bye for now
yeah that's right thank you sir
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign